One thing that kept cropping up and it's
something that crops up every time I
teach this course, and I should always
say something about it preemptively.
It's just a terminological issue.
Israelites are not as Railey's.
Um,
the word Israeli term Israeli refers to
a citizen of the modern state of Israel.
So there are no Israelis
before the year 1948. Okay.
And we use Israelite to refer to the
ancient inhabitants of the ancient kingdom
of Israel. Okay. So that's
an important distinction.
And I know you hear Israelis and so that's
just a term that people thought would
apply to anyone who inhabited
a place called Israel.
But Israeli and Israelite
are used precisely in order
to make that distinction
between the ancient and the modern period.
Okay.
So we're talking about Israel lights
and while we're on the subject,
we're not talking about Jews yet either.
We can't really use the term Jew.
It's not historically accurate for the
period that we've been dealing with in
the Bible.
When we get towards the very end of the
biblical period and we've see that, uh,
when Persia conquers and reconstitutes
this area or designates as a province,
this area as you who'd,
right?
So the Persians are going
to be the ones to create
a province called [inaudible] in
this area, including Jerusalem.
And they will allow the Israelites who
were in exile to go back and live there
and they will become you who dates and
this is going to be where the word Jew
comes from,
but that's not going to be historically
accurate before the end of the sixth
century. Okay. So, and even then,
it's still a technical term having to
do with living in the province Eva,
who is not an ethnic, uh,
an ethnic term, right?
The word you who did you doesn't become
an ethnic term for quite some time.
So Israelites a is the correct term for
the group that we're dealing with here.
Hebrew is not bad either.
It basically is a linguistic term that
refers to people who speak Hebrew. Um,
and so the Hebrews,
it's something of a social ethnic term,
but based mainly on the linguistic
feature of speaking Hebrew. Okay.
So no Israelis, only
Israelites. All right.
We were reaching the end of June of
Joshua and we're going to be moving on to
judges today. And the Bible
describes the early Israelite,
a sociopolitical unit as the tribe.
And this is what's going to be featured
in the last part of the book of Joshua.
We're going to see that
tribes are territorial units.
Tribe is attached to a
territory within the tribe.
You have clan elders and the clan elders
are the ones who dispense justice.
They make decisions regarding
the general welfare of the tribe.
So the second half of the book of Joshua,
um,
so the first half recounts the Conquest,
uh,
and then the second half recounts the
division of the land among the 12 tribes
who it is claimed we're descended
from the 12 sons of Jacob.
We have a couple of different
lists of the tribes in the Bible.
So if you take a look sometime you
might want to compare the list.
That's in genesis.
Genesis 29 or 30,
it's a pretty much the same
list that's in genesis 49. Um,
these are in a blessings,
you know,
patriarchs will very often give a blood
the blessings of all their children.
And so you look at the names
of the children and you'll
see the list of 12. Um,
you had the six sons of layer, you have
the four sons of the two concubines,
Bilhah and Zilpah and the two sons
of Rachel, Joseph and Benjamin.
And that is probably the
oldest list that we have.
But if you compare it to numbers 26,
I'm in Joshua and,
and the list that's in Joshua with
the distribution of the land, um,
you'll see that lavey or Levi is not
included presumably because the Levi's who
were to function as a priestly class
in Israel, they have no land allotment,
right? They're supported through
the cultic practices and the,
and the perquisites that come from
the sacrifices. Um, and so, uh,
instead of the Levites,
we find that too,
there are tribes named for
the two sons of Joseph.
So there is no Joseph tribe per se.
Joseph's two sons are f rhyme and
Menasha and this is how we then reach the
number 12.
So there's no Levi in the later lists,
but the Joseph tribes have been split
into a Fryman Menasha, if you will,
who are said to be the
two sons of Joseph Joseph.
So the consensus is a scholarly consensus
is that what you have in Canaan isn't
alliance of tribes, perhaps
not precisely 12. You know,
at different times there might've been
a different number and different groups
that came together at
different times. But, uh,
you have these tribes who
are worshiping, yeah, way,
perhaps not exclusively as we've seen.
And they have some loose obligations
of mutual defense in these different
alliances.
The book of Joshua presents this very
idealized portrait of these 12 tribes who
are preexistence.
They come into the land of Canaan
already formed basically as 12 tribes are
United with one another by their covenant
with Yahweh and they conquer the land
in concert.
Um,
but there are other elements
of the biblical narrative
as we've already begun to
talk about. And we'll continue to talk
about today as we move into judges,
which really suggests there was much more
sporadic cooperation among the tribes.
We never have more than one or two really
acting in concert until the very end
of the book of judges.
And so this suggests that there really
was no super tribal government or
coordination at this early age.
The Ark is said to have circulated
among the different tribal territories.
Didn't rest permanently in the territory
of one tribe until somewhat late in the
period it comes to rest
at a place called Shilo.
Shilo,
uh,
and it's seems that only in extraordinary
cases would you have the tribes acting
together perhaps by decision
of the tribal elders,
but super imposed upon the authority of
the elders is the authority of certain
inspired individuals.
And these are known as judges and it is
the exploits of these individuals that
are recorded in the book of judges. And
we'll turn to the book of judges. Now
the book of judges is set in that
transitional period between the death of
Joshua and the establishment
of a monarchic system.
It's about a 200 year period
from about 1200 to a 1000 or so.
It is an imaginative and embellished
reconstruction of that period of
transition.
We'll also see it's a very ideologically,
ideologically laden reconstruction.
So the story's depet depict
local tribal skirmishes, um,
rather than confrontations
between nations. You have
pretty much skirmishes with,
with groups around the country and that
makes a lot of sense for this 200 year
period when Canaan is making a transition,
a transition from sort of city states
in the bronze age to the emerging nation
of what we'll be Israel next to it.
Philistia on the east side around.
So we have nations are going to be coming
into being by the end of this period,
but there's this 200 year transitional
period before you get the formation of
these independent states.
Like Joshua,
the book of judges consists of various
sources that were fused together in a
Deuteronomistic framework and
we'll come back to that. In fact,
it's really a collection of individual
stories that senator on local heroes,
several of whom are interestingly enough,
socially marginal.
These are pretty scrappy characters.
You've got the illegitimate son of
a prostitute, you've got a bandit,
you've got very interesting,
colorful, and as I say,
socially marginal people and the stories
have a real folkloristic flavor to
them. They're full of drama
and a lot of local color,
local references to places
and, and um, customs and so on.
So if you were to list the stories of
the various judges, the major judges,
we have, um, six major
in six minor judges.
And my inner judges is simply a reference
to the fact that they judged for a
certain period of time. So there's
12 listed in all, I believe. And the,
there are six major judges for whom
there is a lengthy story beginning with a
who'd and chapter three.
So very a very funny story.
And I'm against the,
they who had leaves the Israelites against
the mower bites a lot of about sort
of bathroom humor in that one. In chapters
four and five, you have Deborah who,
um, helps the Israelites in battle
against certain Canaanite groups.
You have three chapters, four
chapters, chapters six through nine,
recording the adventures
of Gideon, Gideon, uh, uh,
fights against the Midianites.
Gideon is interesting.
There are signs in his story
that he is divinely chosen.
I mean there's some evidence of,
of the enunciation of his birth and
some signal that he is divinely chosen.
Then in I'm 11 and into a
little bit of chapter 12,
you have the story of youth talk or
Jephthah who fights against the ammonites.
Very, um, interesting and
tragic story of his daughter,
which echoes similar sorts of stories.
And in Greek,
in Greek legend,
you also have chapters 13 to 16 Samson
who of course fights against the
Philistines. Sampson is
somewhat atypical. Um,
he also has a,
a,
a tremendous and fatal
weakness for foreign women
and that's a strong throughout
the Samson stories.
We'll come back to some of that.
Then towards the end you have
some interesting chapters
at the end, 17 and 18,
tell the story of Mika or Micah
and his idolatrous shrine.
And then finally the quite
horrifying and gruesome tail, um,
beginning chapters 19
going on through 20 and 21,
the story of the Levites conky
mine, um, and the civil war.
We'll come back and talk about
some of these a little more detail,
but that's just to give you a sense of
the different units that are in the story.
And then these are that are in the book.
And these stories have then been
embedded in a Deuteronomistic framework.
This framework provides the editors view
and pronouncement on and judgment of
the period.
Um,
some of the stories seem to have been
left pretty much intact themselves or
isn't in many cases a lot of
interference inside the story. Um,
only a few interpretations that express
the editors a theology of history,
but the editors theology of history is
best seen in the preface to the book,
which is why I sort of stuck
these over to the side. Um, this,
this preface that that frames the book
and chapter one gives a detailed summary
of the situation at the end of
Joshua's conquest, right? Taking stock,
listing the extensive areas that Joshua
had failed to take from the Canaanites,
despite the impression that's given by
the book of Joshua is certainly the first
part of it. They did everything they were
supposed to have done and fulfilled, uh,
the commandments to Moses and so on.
But here we get a list of all the places
they failed to take from the Canaanites
starting in Judah and moving
northward. They tend to, uh,
tend always start in the southern area
and Judah and then listings northward
direction.
Then in judges two verses one
through five and angel appears, um,
before Josh was death and
the Angel Recounts God's
redemption of the Israelites
from Egypt and then quotes God as follows,
I will never break my covenant
with you, but you, for your part,
must make no covenant with
the inhabitants of the land.
You must tear down their altars.
That's a phrase that's frowned.
And Deuteronomy 12 again,
one of those phrases that makes us link
Deuteronomy with all of these subsequent
books and we refer to it all as a school,
the Deuteronomistic school,
because we have these phrases from
Deuteronomy that we'll pepper be peppered
throughout the rest of these books.
God will be faithful to his covenant,
in other words, but it's a two way
street and if Israel doesn't do her part,
she will be punished to the editor is
setting us up with that expectation before
we even begin to read an
account of what happens.
The Angel then relates that Israel
has already not been obedient,
so God has resolved, right? This
is a fait accompli. At this point,
God has resolved that he will no longer
drive the Canaanites out before the
Israelites.
He will leave them as a snare and a
trap to test their resolve and their
loyalty.
So it's a very far cry from the idealized
portrait that we had in the first half
of the book of Joshua.
So that opening announcement listing all
of the ways in which they have failed
to take the and the visit by the Angel
who tells them you've already failed in
so many ways,
and so God's not even going to help
you to route the Canaanites any longer.
That's followed.
Then in a section from chapter two verse
11 through Chapter Three Verse six and
this is a kind of prospective summary,
write a summary before the
fact of the nation's troubles,
and this is a passage that expresses the
editor's judgment on the nation of this
period.
Another generation arose after them,
which had not experienced
the Lord experience the
deliverance of the Lord or the
deeds that he had brought for Israel and
the Israelites did what was offensive
to the Lord, but was literally what was
evil in the eyes of the Lord, right?
If an important phrase,
what was evil in the eyes of the Lord,
they followed other gods from among the
gods of the peoples around them and bow
down to them.
They provoked the Lord.
Then the Lord was incensed it Israel
and he handed them over to foes who
plundered them as the Lord had declared
and as the Lord had sworn to them and
they were in great distress.
And then the Lord raised up leaders who
delivered them from those who plundered
them, but they did not
heed their leaders either.
They want a straight after
other gods and bow down to them.
And when though I'm sort of skipping
right, I'm condensing all of this.
When the Lord raised up leaders for them,
the Lord would be with the leader and
would save them from their enemies during
the leader's lifetime for the Lord
would be moved to pity by their mornings
because of those who oppressed and
crushed them. But when the leader died,
they would act.
They would again act basically even more
than the preceding generation following
other gods were shipping
them and bowing down to them.
They omitted none of their practices
and stubborn ways. So in short,
it's the view of the Deuteronomistic
historian expressed here in judges that
Israel's crises are caused
by her infidelity to your
way through the worship of
Canaanite gods.
And for this sin,
God sells the Israelites to their enemies
and then move to pity when they cry
out.
Um,
under the oppression he raises
leaders to deliver Israel.
And this pattern of sin,
punishment, repentance,
and deliverance through leaders, um, is
the recurring pattern throughout the book.
And it punctuates the transition from
each of these leaders that God will raise
up,
right?
So it's this recurring pattern and this
Deuteronomistic perspective as well as
Deuteronomistic ideology generally isn't
always apparent within the individual
stories themselves.
As I stressed,
some of them seem to be
pre Deuteronomistic folk
tales about the exploits of
these local heroes.
They were popular stories.
So Gideon we'll see builds an altar,
uh,
despite the fact that we know Deuteronomy
insisted on centralized worship and
prohibited outlying alters
or multiple alters. Um,
he is also known. His
other name, if you will,
is [inaudible] howl.
I just a name that's made with bow,
um, meaning, um, about Al will
strive or buyable content.
So this is an alternate name for
Gideon. He erects an idol. Uh,
the people of chef him where he is,
I'm after his death.
They continue to worship by,
I'll burrito the bow of the covenant,
which was an interesting sort of merger
of Bile Ism and covenantal religion,
right?
So you have a lot of these elements
that presumably the deuteronomist would
disapprove.
The story of Sampson also appears
to be largely pre Deuteronomistic.
It was again,
probably a very popular entertaining
folktale about a legendary strong man.
Um, you know, he can lift
up the gates of the city,
he can tie the tales of 300
foxes with torches and so on.
Um, but this great strong man
is undone by his one weakness,
which is a weakness for foreign women,
particularly Philistine women.
At least we think Delilah was Philistine.
And that proves to be his downfall.
So you can see in a way how these stories
were fodder for the Deuteronomistic
editor.
The Deuteronomistic editor insists that
foreign gods often accessed through
marriage to foreign women,
exercised a fatal attraction for Israel.
And it was the inability to resist the
snare of idolatry that would ultimately
lead to ruin. We have to remember that
the final editing of this, of these,
these, um, this narrative history
is happening in exile, right?
It's happening from people for whom all
of this is ultimately leading towards a
tragedy.
All right?
So the leaders who are raised
by God are called judges.
That's a term that's used
in other Semitic texts, um,
to refer to leaders in
the second millennium,
sometimes human and sometimes divine.
Um,
so the term is used here in the biblical
text that we fear refers always to a
human leader and one who exercises
many different powers or functions,
not merely judicial. We think of the word
judge really in a judicial context in,
but that's not, that wasn't the
extent of the function of the judge.
These are light judge was
actually primarily a military
leader commissioned with
a specific task.
And only in times of national crisis,
the judge had a charismatic
quality, which, um,
in several cases as
expressed by the phrase,
the spirit of the Lord came upon him.
God would raise up the judge to deliver
the people from a specific crisis.
The judge might muster troops
from two tribes or three tribes,
sometimes only a clan or two,
which suggests that there was wrote no
real national entity at this particular
time. We never see more than one or two
tribes acting together or some clans of a
tribe, but the institution
of judges never, um,
created fixed political,
uh,
forms and each judge deferred from the
last in background in class and even
gender. We do have one
female judge Deborah, who did
exercise judicial functions.
Evidently according to the text,
the judges aren't chosen
necessarily for their virtue.
Many of them seem to fall into the
literary type of the trickster.
You know, a bit like Jacobs. Some of
them are, they're crafty, tricky types.
A Gideon is explicitly chosen for his
weakness and not because of his strength.
Turns out that he's quite a ruthless
fighter and he's clearly not a devout Yak.
Whist. Um, Jephthah is an outlaw.
Samson is hardly a moral exemplar.
So these are not meant to be
idealized heroes, but popular heroes.
And there a very interesting tension,
uh,
in the book of judges that will continue
beyond and to book of Samuel as well.
But attention regarding kingship,
the individual stories seem to suggest
a very deep seated distrust of kingship.
So in judges eight,
the people ask one of the judges,
Gideon at that time to become king.
And he responds this way,
I shall not rule over you, nor shall
my son's rule over you, Yahweh.
He shall rule over you.
That's eight,
verse 23 and indeed the short rain of
Gideon's ruthless son of the Melech,
which means my father is king,
ironically, um, is a complete disaster.
The position of judge is temporary.
God was viewed as the
permanent king in Israel,
the temporary authority of the judge
derived from the kingship of God.
So the judge's position could
not become absolute or permanent.
That would be a rejection
of God's leadership.
So the book of judges seems to be
squarely against the notion of kingship in
Israel,
but the book as a whole seems to suggest
a certain progression towards kingship.
And this emerges from some of the kind of
editorial elements and interpretations.
The final chapters of judges document
Israel's slow slide into disorder and
ultimately into civil war.
Chapter 18 opens with an ominous statement
or phrase that recurs throughout the
final chapters. In those days,
there was no king in Israel.
Uh,
that happens again in Chapter 19 Verse
One Chapter 21 verse 25 and in addition,
it is said that everyone
did as he pleased,
or everyone did what was
right in his own eyes.
It's in chapter 21 verse
25 by the end of the book,
the Israelites find themselves spiraling
out of control in an orgy of violence
and rape.
And in the final chapter,
all out civil war alleviates concubine,
is raped by a gang murdered
by the tribe of Benjamin.
And this is an atrocity that's to a
be avenged by all the other tribes.
They leave. Eit takes her
body, cuts it into 12 parts,
sends a part to each of the
tribes as a call to war,
to join together in a war of
extermination against Benjamin.
And many scholars have observed that.
It's ironic and tragic that the onetime
the tribes do all act in concert is
against one of their own.
This is the only time all 12 tribes or
if the other 11 tribes come out against a
common enemy and it is the tribe of
Benjamin at a certain point, however,
they realize with some regret that the
tribe of Benjamin is near extinction.
This is not a good thing.
So the other tribes then arrange to kidnap
women from Shiloh as mates Shilo for,
for the remaining Benjamin Nights.
So as a final comment on this horrible
symphony of barbarity of rape,
murder, civil war,
kidnapping, forced marriage,
the Deuteronomistic his story
and concludes the book of
judges with this refrain.
In those days, there was no king in
Israel and every man did. Is he pleased?
Right? It's a wonderfully,
um, polysomic phrase,
no king in Israel, no human king,
perhaps also given their behavior,
no divine king. Um, so again, I see that
as sort of an ominous refrain throughout.
There was no king in Israel.
Every man is doing as it pleases.
And look at the situation we've reached
by the end of the book of judges,
the Deuteronomistic,
a explanation for the moral and
social bankruptcy of Israel.
At the end of the period of the judges
and the dawn or the on the eve of the
monarchy is Israel's
continued in fidelity.
And the prescription for this situation
at some level in the texts is a king.
This sits uneasily with an anti
monarchic trend in some of these stories.
But according to the
Deuteronomistic historian,
the institutional structure
of a kingdom of God,
right to sort of a theocracy is how a
later Jewish historian would describe this
period at kingdom in
which God is the king.
And the community is led by inspired
judges in times of crisis. That structure,
that institutional structure
failed to establish stability,
um, uh, stable, continuous government.
It failed to provide leadership against
Israel's enemies within and without you,
if I'm on and Moab to the east,
you have the Philistines to the west
and they soon managed to subjugate the
entire land.
So the tribes seem to be conscious of
the need for a centralized authority,
a strong central authority.
And the demand for a king arises in their
search for a new political order that
people turn to the Prophet Samuel.
Samuel is the last,
the last in a line of profit judges.
Um,
uh, and they ask him to
anoint a king for them.
So we're moving now into the book of
Samuel and the Book of Samuel deals with
the transition from the period of the
judges to the period of the monarchy.
And the first book of Samuel,
you have the opening chapters that record
the birth and career of Israel's last
judge Samuel. So that's chapters one
through four. The next few chapters, um,
through seven deal with the
Philistine crisis. And at this time,
the Ark of the covenant itself is captured
and taken into Philistine territory.
Um,
chapters eight through 15,
give us a story of Samuel and Saul
who will be Israel's first king.
And then the last half of the,
of the book,
16 onto 31 are going to,
um,
give us the story of Saul and David.
So first Samuel opens with the story
of Samuel's birth to Hannah and her
dedication of her son to the
service of God at Shiloh,
at the sanctuary at Shiloh.
So Shiloh appears to have been the most
important shrine in the period before
the monarchy.
The Prophet Jeremiah is going to refer
to shy though as the place where God
first made his name to dwell.
You remember,
the Deuteronomist is always speaking
about centralization around a place where
God will cause his name to
dwell. At first, that was Shiloh.
It's been noted that after
the birth of Samuel, um,
the text conveys a sense of three crises
and I've sort of listed them on the far
side of the board over there.
The first crisis is a religious crisis.
The priest of the time,
Aly Eli,
he's also described as a judge,
but perhaps that's just to fit him
literarily into the pattern of leadership
that predominates in this
section of the Bible.
He's said to be aging and his sons
are quite corrupt. As a result,
the text says the word of
Yahweh is rare in those days.
So there's a crisis in
religious leadership.
There's also a crisis in political
leadership or political succession to some
degree.
Um,
judges two tells us that Eli's
two sons are clearly not worthy.
They dishonor the sacrifices
and according to one reading,
they lie with the women
at the door of the shrine.
God says he will cut off
the power of Eli's house.
His two sons will die in one day and
God will find and raise up a faithful
priest. But in the meantime,
no leader is a parent.
So we have a crisis in succession,
if you will.
The third crisis is a military crisis.
In judges four through seven,
um,
the Israelites suffer a defeat
at the hands of the Philistines.
I'm sorry for Samuel. Um, they suffer a
defeat at the hands of the Philistines.
The arc is captured.
Eli's two sons are killed.
And the news of all of
this kills Eli as well.
So when we first meet Samuel,
we wonder,
is he going to be the answer to all
of these crises, these problems?
Chapter three says that the word of
the word of God comes to Israel through
Samuel.
I,
in contrast to the statement that the
word of God was rare in those days,
we hear that the word of God is now
coming to Israel through Samuel.
It raises some hope in
Chapter Seven Samuel Exhorts,
the people to stop serving
alien gods and Ashley Roach,
and to serve God and only then will god
deliver them so that people do this.
And Samuel lead them.
He employs his,
his military tactics mostly include
prayer and confession and sacrifice,
but he manages to,
uh,
lead them to victory over the Philippine
Philistine's God thunders and the
Philistines Flea in fear.
So Samuel seems to be combining
in one person several functions.
He is a priest. He's in the shrine.
He offers sacrifices. He builds.
Alters is also a seer and a prophet.
He receives the word of the Lord.
And like a prophet,
he will be annointing kings.
And he's also a judge in the sense that
he leads Israel to military victory.
But he also travels a circuit acting
as a judge in a judicial sense.
Um,
it says throughout Israel,
but really most of the places we hear
about are within the confines of Benjamin.
So this story seems to mostly be
focused in the southern region,
in the tribe of Benjamin,
but even he is unable to provide Israel
with the kind of leadership that, uh,
the texts suggests is required.
The philistine threat is going to
reemerge and the crisis of succession will
remain obviously.
And so the representatives of
the 12 tribes come together
to Samuel to ask for a
king.
Samuel is therefore a kind of a
transition figure between Israel,
the semi Democratic
Confederation and Israel,
the nation and monarchy.
It's going to be a huge
transformation as we'll see,
but he's going to be the one to bridge
the gap to this new kind of leadership.
Now, as an judges, um,
the historical account that we
have in first Samuel contains many
contradictions,
many duplicates.
So scholars take these as evidence of
the existence of various conflicting
sources and traditions that have been
put together in a larger framework.
So for example, we have three
different accounts of, of um,
the choice of Saul as king. We have
two accounts of his being rejected.
Ultimately by God.
We have different accounts of how David
came to know Saul and how David entered
Saul Service.
We have more than one account of David's
escape into Philistine territory of his
sparing Saul's life. That
happens twice, twice.
He has the opportunity to kill him twice.
He spares his life and so on.
Goliath is killed twice.
Only one of those occasions is by David
and the other occasion he's killed by
some other hero.
So most important for us,
however is the existence of sources that
hold opposing views of the institution
of kingship. This makes for an interesting
and complicated structure in the book.
Some of the passages are clearly
antinarcotic and some are clearly promo
anarchic and I've put them up here.
The anti monarchic passages.
First Samuel eight there's a passage in
10 there's a passage and 12 the promo
anarchic passages are sandwiched in
between these right and nine and 11 so you
have this alternating sequence
of anti pro, anti pro,
anti first Samuel Eight is a classic
example of the antimony narcotic
perspective. Samuel is initially
opposed to the whole idea.
He apparently resents the use or patient
of his own power until God says he the
demand of the people and everything
they say to you for it is not you.
They have rejected it is me.
They have rejected as their king,
he their demand,
but warn them solidly and tell them
about the practices of any king who will
rule over them.
And so Samuel does that.
He does that in verses 11 through
18 he wards of the tyranny of kings,
the repair seriousness of kings,
the service and the sacrifice that we
choir of the people in order to support
their luxurious court life.
And they're large Harem,
their bureaucracy and their army.
The Day will come Samuel Warren's when
you cry out because of the king whom you
yourselves have chosen and the Lord will
not answer you on that day. All right,
very antimony narky passage that people
won't listen to him and they say quite
significantly.
No,
we must have a king over us that we may
be like all the other nations that are
king rule over us and go out at
our head and fight our battles.
So this is an explicit and ominous
rejection that only have Yaffe way,
but of Israel's distinctiveness from other
nations and what after all it does it
mean to be a holy nation,
but to be a nation separated out from
observing different rules from other
nations.
In Samuel 12 Samuel retires and he says
as he does so see it is the king who
leads you.
Now I am old and gray and he again
outlines what is required of a good king.
And then again chastises the people
for even having asked for a king,
a warning that really God
must be served wholeheartedly.
A king should not interpose himself.
Some have argued that the editors who
compiled the text preserved the Promo
anarchic perspective of their sources,
but they chose to frame the promo
anarchic passages with their own antum
anarchic passages with the result that
the anti monarchic passage is really
provide a, um, a stronger interpretive
framework and our dominant.
And the implication is that despite
positive contemporary evaluations of
Israel's kings from the perspective of
a later period, from the perspective of,
of the editors and perhaps
those sitting in exile,
the institution of kingship
was a disaster for Israel.
And that negative assessment is introduced
by the Deuteronomistic redactor into
his account of the origin
of the institution that
God himself warrant at the
time that this transition was being made.
And this request was being made.
God himself warned that this had the
potential to be quite disastrous.
Others feel that the Promo anarchic and
anti Menarche fuse were contemporaneous
and both ancient. And we see that simply
reflected in these dueling sources.
So whether one view is
older and one a more recent,
whether both are ancient views or
both are recent or later views,
the end result is a very complex
narrative. As you read it,
you feel thrown back and forth between
these positive and negative assessments
of kingship.
Um,
and we feel these and see these very
different views of monarchy in ancient
Israel. So these views really
defy categorization. In the end,
they're one of the things that give the
book such complexity and sophistication.
Not only is their ambivalence,
however,
about the institution
of kingship or monarchy,
there's also a great deal of ambivalence
about the first and habitat of the
office. The first King
King Saul himself, uh,
judges has three different accounts
of Saul's appointment as king.
In chapter nine for Samuel Nine,
it's a private affair.
It's just between Saul
and the Prophet Samuel.
Samuel anoints Saul as king with oil
and a kind of a private encounter.
The anointing of kings is also found
among other ancient near eastern groups.
The Hittites, for example, in Israel,
it seems to be a right of dedication
or consecration, making sacred to God,
consecration making sacred,
and it's done not just for kings,
it's also done for high priests.
They are also anointed with sacred oil.
Then in First Samuel 10,
you have Saul's appointment
represented as um,
being affected by lottery. It's a
lottery that's presided over by Samuel,
but there is a lottery system and the
lot falls to Samuel to be appointed king.
In the next chapter. In
First Samuel 11, we have, um,
Saul victorious in a
battle over the ammonites.
And so he's elected by popular
acclaim, if you will. Um,
these could all be complimentary ways
of his slowly securing the position.
Um, they could be seen as
competing accounts, but he's a,
an important and a striking figure.
Nevertheless,
there seems to have been some controversy
about Saul and it's preserved within
our sources. On the one
hand, he's described in very
positive terms. He's tall,
he's handsome, he's winning,
he's charismatic. In fact,
he's associated with ecstatic prophecy
at the spirit of the Lord comes upon him
and he,
he prophesies in that in a,
in a sort of a raving and dancing and
ecstatic mode. He defends his own tribe.
He's from the tribe of Benjamin and he
defends them from ammonite raids and he's
hailed by the tribes as a
leader in time of war as king.
He did enjoy some initial
military victories.
He drove the Philistines from their
garrisons and he was such a popular and
natural leader that even Samuel,
who at first resented Saul and resented
the idea that king came to appreciate
him and was said to really
grieve for him upon his death.
But once David enters the story,
which is about halfway through the book
of First Samuel, um, it's per Samuel 16,
then we begin to see, begin to see
clearly negative assessments of saw,
perhaps because the sources about David
does stem from circles that were loyal
to the house of David and
David is going to succeed.
Saul obviously as the
second king of Israel.
Perhaps the negative
assessment is because of cells,
Saul's ultimate failure and suicide.
And that had to be accounted for by
identifying some fatal flaw in him.
So now his ecstatic prophecies
are presented as irrational
fits of mad behavior.
So where once the spirit of the
Lord was said to come upon him,
now he said to be seized by
an evil spirit from the Lord,
that Russia's upon him suddenly
causing him to rave in his house, uh,
elsewhere.
He commits errors.
He doesn't obey Samuel's instructions to
the letter and that's going to cost him
the support of Samuel.
And ultimately, God,
we have two stories of disobedience
unrelated in First Samuel.
One is in chapter 13 he sees 'em that
the morale of his men is sagging.
And so to sort of rallied them together,
he officiates at a sacrifice.
He was supposed to wait for Samuel
to arrive and do it, but he,
he sees that it needs to happen now.
And so he officiates at the sacrifice
himself and this appropriation of a
priestly function and rages Samuel.
And this is Samuel's first pronouncement
or prediction that God will not
establish Saul's dynasty over
Israel despite the fact, by the way,
that other kings at other times we'll
sacrifice with impunity. So it's,
it's interesting because David
and others will sacrifice and,
and it doesn't seem to be a problem,
but here it's given as the occasion
for Samuel's fury and his first
pronouncement that the dynasty
of Saul will not be established.
In Chapter 15 we have a second instance
of disobedience that earns Samuel's
disapproval again against Samuel's order.
He spares the life of an enemy
king. This king a Gog, um,
he spares his life and otherwise
violates the terms of hire him. You know,
this notion of total destruction or
devotion of booty and enemies to God,
um, through total destruction.
And again, when he violates the,
the order of Krm,
Samuel again announces that God
regrets having made Saul King.
The Lord has this day torn
the kingship over Israel,
away from you and has given it to
another who is worthier than you.
That's Chapter 15, verse 28. In any event,
with his support eroding,
Saul seems to sink into a
deep depression and paranoia.
And toward the end of his life,
he's depicted as being completely obsessed
with David and the threat that David
poses to saw himself,
but also his dynasty saw is
angry that his own son, Jonathan,
who presumably should succeed
him to the throne, um,
has a deep friendship with David and in
fact throws his support over to David
instead of himself in, in
several jealous rages, um,
saw attempts to kill David or to have
him at his supporters killed a one
particularly violent infinity. Kills
85 priests who he believes have, um,
given shelter to David and his supporters.
So in these encounters, right
between Saul and David, um,
the sources portray Saul is this,
this raving obsessed, paranoid person.
And David is seen as a
sort of innocent victim.
And he protests his loyalty
and his support for Saul.
He doesn't seem to understand why saw,
should view him as a threat.
And twice he passes up the opportunity
to do a way with Saul himself.
He says, I will not raise my
hand against the Lord's anointed.
So the portrayal of Saul is a raving and
paranoid man who's obsessed with David,
probably reflects the views of later.
Writers who are apologists
for the house of David.
Positive views of Saul's character weren't
entirely extinguished by the biblical
writer. David, uh,
David's own lament when he
hears of Saul's death by, um,
by suicide and Jonathan's death also may
reflect Saul's tremendous popularity.
David orders the Judah Heights to sing
what's called the song of the bow in
praise of Saul. Your glory. Oh,
Israel lies slain on your heights.
How have the mighty
fallen Saul and Jonathan,
beloved and cherished never
parted in life or in death.
They were swifter than eagles.
They were stronger than lions.
Daughters of Israel weep over Saul
who closed you in Crimson and finery,
who decked your robes with jewels of gold.
How have the mighty fallen
in the thick of battle?
Jonathan slain on your heights. I
grieve for you. My brother Jonathan.
You were most dear to me.
Your Love was wonderful to me.
More than the love of women.
How have the mighty fallen,
the weapons of war perished,
of course representing David as Bill
Wailing Saul and Jonathan in these terms
would have served and
apologetic function as well.
David is cleared of any part in or
even desire for the death of Saul.
So halfway through the book of Samuel
then, um, is the first part of,
of the story of David and his encounters
with saw running through to the end of
first Samuel and the first few chapters
of second Samuel about second Samuel
Five.
And this whole section,
this first part of the story of David
has the feel of a historical novel or um,
or narrative. It's it, there's lots
of direct speech and lots of dialogue.
So it has the feel of a fiction of a novel
given that the ruling family in Judah
was referred to as the house of David
for several centuries and given a
wonderful archeological find
dating from the ninth century. Um,
it's a Syrian inscription that
refers to the House of David.
I'm dating to the ninth century.
So given some of those, those,
those two pieces of evidence,
I think most scholars would
see David as a real person.
None of the details of the biblical
account can really be confirmed. Um,
of course. But I think the consensus
is that David was a real person.
There are obviously some who do not hold
that and believe this is a much later
retro ejection vector rejection.
But David is surprisingly enough,
presented as very human.
He's not a divine character and he's
certainly not even a highly virtuous
character.
The first installment of his story through
about second Samuel five is clearly
sympathetic to David
and favorable to David,
but it's not entirely
obsequious or flattering,
which is the sort of genre that we very
often have coming out of an ancient near
eastern texts dealing with royalty.
This part of the story may
be an apology for David,
but it's also subtly critical of him.
Certainly David is a hero,
but if you read between the lines, he's
also an opportunist. He's an outlaw.
He serves as a mercenary for the
Philistines for some of the time,
and he can act pretty unscrupulously.
So this isn't royal propaganda
in the simple sense,
even though to some degree it
may be an apology for David.
As we're going to see in a minute,
David will fare much,
much worse in the second
installment of his story.
And this is the story that takes up
the bulk of second Samuel. Right.
So moving now into the book of Second
Samuel and the latter part of David's
story.
Um,
actually no,
I lied.
We're going to back up for one minute
just to talk about the different accounts
of Davidson merchants, right? The
three different stories, if you will,
of David's discovery.
Because in the first Samuel again
secretly sort of annoyance, um,
him king of Judah.
So it's a,
it's a private affair and he announced
them and now annoyance him as the king of
Judah, which is just the southern region.
Uh, and he does this installs lifetime.
David is the youngest of his father's son.
So this anointment is another
reversal of primogenitor,
the Xl Taishan of the lowly that
we see so often in the Bible.
In the second account,
we first meet David when he is summoned
to play music for a disturbed Saul who
of course is suffering from
these irrational fits. Um,
and then in the third account, David
is introduced as the, you know,
98 pound weakling who takes
on the legendary Goliath.
Later after the death of Saul,
David will be anointed king in
Hebron over his own tribe, Judah.
He then manages to either win over or
kill off the rest of Saul's household.
Anyone else who could make a dynastic
claim to the throne based on descent from
saw a,
anyone who might be a threat to his
claim to kingship in the more northern
region. And eventually the northern
tribes will also elect him king.
And so the United kingship of the
northern parts of Israel and the,
and the tribe of Judah is finally formed.
Once his reign seems secure and the
nation is consolidated behind him,
David then captures Jerusalem and launches
attacks against Israel's neighbors.
And the text says that the
Lord gives him victory.
This is in second Samuel eight now and um,
versus six and 14.
God gives him victory.
The Biblical narrative depicts them
as the master of a huge empire that
stretches from the desert to the sea.
There's very little evidence
that Israel actually, um,
established lasting control over
all of the states in this region.
It's likely that David was able to
take advantage of a power vacuum.
Egypt's hold on. Canaan was
crumbling. Um, the, again,
the migration of these peoples of the
seas throughout this region and other
people's pressing in from the desert
had really upset. And, um, uh,
the two major powers right in Mesopotamia
and in Egypt and they really had lost
control of the central region.
And so David was,
and the Israelites were able to take
advantage of this and establish an
independent state.
And David's independent state was
probably able to dominate the area for a
little while. Um, ending the
Philistine threat, for example,
and possibly even collecting tribute
from some of the surrounding our
neighboring states.
I'm on and Moab and Itam,
but it's the prophet Nathan who
transmits God's promise to David,
a promise that will become the basis
for the faith in the eternity of the
Davidic kingdom. And that happens
in Second Samuel Chapter seven,
verses eight to 17.
Very important passage and very important
in the construction of what we'll see
is a royal ideology or royal ideology
that comes to contest some of the basic
ideology of the nation. Thus says the
Lord of hosts. This is Nathan speaking.
Now I'm quoting God,
thus says the Lord of hosts.
I took you from the pasture from following
the sheep that you should be prince
over my people,
Israel and I have been with you wherever
you went and have cut off all your
enemies from before you and I will make
for you a great name like the name of
the great ones of the earth and I
will appoint a place for my people,
Israel and will plant them that they
may dwell in their own place and be
disturbed.
No more and violent men shall afflict
them no more as formerly from the time
that I appointed judges over my people,
Israel and I will give you rest
from all your enemies. Moreover,
the Lord declares to you that
the Lord will make you a house,
meaning here dynasty.
When your days are fulfilled and
you lie down with your fathers,
I will raise up your offspring after you
who shall come forth from your body and
I will establish his kingdom.
He shall build a house,
Ma meaning now he temple for my name
and I will establish the throne of his
kingdom forever. I will be his
father and he shall be my son.
When he commits iniquity,
I will chase in him with the rod of men
with the stripes of the sons of men,
but I will not take my steadfast
love from him as I took it from Saul,
whom I put away from before you and your
house and your kingdom shall be made
sure forever before me.
Your throne shall be established forever
in accordance with all these words and
in accordance with all this vision.
Nathan spoke to David.
It's a very important passage and it's
with this passage that you have the idea
of an eternal,
an unconditional covenant between God
and the House of David or the dynasty of
David. And this is now the fourth covenant
that we've met, the Noaa Hide Covenant,
the Patriarchal Covenant, the Synetic
Covenant, and now the Davidic covenant.
Note that God says that David and his
descendants may be punished for sin.
They certainly will be punished for sin,
but he will not take the kingdom
away from them as he did from Saul.
So God's oath to preserve the
Davidic dynasty. And by implication,
we'll see later next
time Jerusalem as well,
would lead eventually to a popular belief
in the invincibility of the holy city.
In addition,
the belief in Israel's
ultimate deliverance from
enemies became bound up with
David and his dynasty.
David was idealized by later biblical
and posts biblical tradition and became
the paradigmatic king.
So even when the kingdom fell finally to
the Babylonians in five 86 the promise
to David's house was
believed to be eternal.
The community looked to the future for
a restoration of the Davidic line or a
Davidic king or a messiah.
Now the Hebrew Word Messiah simply
means anointed one who is Mashiah is
anointed, okay, with the holy oil.
That's a reference to the fact that the
king was initiated into office by means
of holy oil being poured on his head.
So King David was the Messiah of God,
the King anointed by or to God.
And in the exile,
Israelites would pray for another messiah,
meaning another king from the House of
David appointed and anointed by God to
rescue them from enemies and reestablish
them as a nation at peace in their land
as David had done.
So the Jewish hope for a messiah be
speaking now in the post biblical so that
where it's correct to say Jewish,
the Jewish hope for a messiah was
thus always political and national and
involved the restoration of the nation
in its land under a Davidic king.
We're going to talk next time about the
royal ideology that begins to emerge and
challenge the older senate.
It can covenantal ideology,
but that's too much to get into now.
So we'll deal with that on Wednesday
and then move on through the rest of the
Deuteronomistic history.